Welcome back everyone,
it's Charlie
Jon Bernthal and Marvel just teased Punisher
returning during Daredevil Born Again Season 1
So we'll break it all down.
There's a bunch of stuff
we already know about the series
and what Punisher is doing during season one.
They just use the Echo Post-Credits scene to set up
what's going to be happening when that picks up.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
of course.
I'll be doing episode videos
when the Daredevil series starts.
They just started filming season one again.
but right after the Echo series premiered last week,
as we've been posting this video,
Jon Bernthal spoke about The Punisher
coming back in Daredevil Born Again.
He said, I think there's a reason
why that character has resonated as deeply
and as strongly as he has in the hearts
and minds of comic book
fans, first responders, people in the military,
people all over the globe.
I think there's a little Frank Castle in everybody.
He exists very strongly inside me,
and I care about that character deeply.
I also know that it's absolutely essential
that we do it.
We do it right.
and we have real sacred integrity to the source
material and to what is at the core of Frank.
And you know how Marvel is.
I really can't say anything anyway.
But I care about Frank deeply.
And no matter how much Frank grows, he's
always going to be the same.
his comments, they're about there being a little Frank
Castle and everyone is a bit of a reference
back to his original Daredevil season
two episodes on Netflix
in his whole conversation with Daredevil
telling him he was one bad day away from being him.
Like The Punisher
is what everybody turns into on their bad days.
and a big part of him coming back was making
sure they did a bang up job with the character.
In the new episode.
It's like, if we're going to bring him back, let's
bring him back. Right.
one of the other funny things, too,
that happened last year,
you might have spotted this,
but it was a bit of a blink and you miss it.
Kind of moment, but it's still up on his page.
Early last year in 2023, right
before they were getting ready to film the brand new
Daredevil Born again episodes like the first version
of the show before they rebooted everything.
he basically revealed that he was coming back like,
the Punisher has returned.
Like, you're definitely coming back.
I can't play.
This video might be completely
just because there's a lot of copyrighted music on it,
but it is the soundtrack for the Punisher series
playing on it as he comes back in,
if you ever see my other Daredevil Born Again videos,
I talk about how Kevin Feige rebooted the new show
Daredevil Born again last year, he fired
the old writers, hired the showrunner from Jon Bernthal
as Punisher Netflix series in the Loki writers
to redo the whole show.
So what a big surprise Punisher
coming back in The Punisher showrunner is coming back.
found out yesterday
that the Punisher was happening again.
So I feel like it's my second chance because it was
the only one of the shows that I wasn't in.
And I love Jon Bernthal,
so let's all make it happen collectively, guys.
We'd be so happy to
bring Sergeant Paul Nice and fight nerds back for sure.
what they changed though,
about the original version of Daredevil Born Again?
They'd already shot about six episodes.
They're still using that material
and just kind of reworking that.
But The Punisher showrunner completely
did a brand new episode one,
then filmed two additional episodes
to finish the first half of season one,
and they just went back to film the rest of season one
and it's meant to be for 18 episodes.
I think what they're going to be doing
is just breaking season one into two halves.
the way the broadcast television
used to work like agents of SHIELD we've been talking
about them canonizing
all of the old shows there used to be a mid-season
break in the middle of these
like 20 episode agents of Shield seasons
speaking of which, Marvel also just canonized
all the Marvel defenders Netflix series to the MCU.
Clarifying that whole question.
Some of you probably always considered
the Netflix stuff to be canon to the MCU
because of the way they made references.
but on a technical level.
It was always a bit of a question mark
in the people who actually made the Echo series
actually addressed this.
up until this point, we've been a little bit cagey
about what's sacred timeline.
What's not sacred timeline that was that was born of,
frankly, a period at the studio where we were like,
we have to stick the landing with Avengers.
Sure.
You know, it was it was another part of the company
developing the Netflix stuff.
We were aware of what they were doing.
They were aware of we were doing.
But it was it was a it was it was a lot.
It was a lot to balance anyway.
But now that, you know, to some time has passed,
now that we see how actually how
well integrated the stories are.
would be confident
in saying it is part of the sacred time.
They basically said that when they were making the Echo
series, they treated all the Marvel Netflix stuff
like it was Canon.
Then right after that interview aired, Marvel
just put all the Netflix Defenders series
into the proper place in the MCU timeline
between all the movies in the show's,
the way that all the producers
who are making all these shows like Kevin Feige,
all those people talked about it
99% of all that Marvel Netflix stuff is canon.
They might change a couple of things.
There might be a couple of recasting as they're
bringing people back because of availability issues.
But for the most part,
pretty much everything that happened on the Marvel
Netflix Defenders series is canon to
what's happening in the new stuff.
so when the Punisher comes back
during Daredevil born again in season
one it'll be the same version of the character
who just got done with Punisher.
Season two, Season one, Daredevil Season two
Now, remember the events of Punisher?
Season two take place several years ago inside the MCU
in the present day MCU, it's meant to be 2026
when Daredevil Born Again
is picking up the Echo series is pretty much a prequel
to Daredevil Born Again.
That still takes place in 2025.
during Echo, they revealed that
neither daredevil nor Kingpin got snapped.
They were around for the entire five year time jump.
it might also be the case
that Punisher did not get snapped either.
So he also did his full ronin during that five year
time.
He's going around
killing as many really bad people as possible
To be fair, though, even though they treated it like
it was a really big twist for the Hawkeye character,
like he became Ronin went super dark, In reality,
that's just another day for the Punisher.
Like The Punisher does stuff like that all the time.
Just on a normal day.
and I know there's a lot of follow up
questions of that now, too.
Like, well, it's a five year time
jump. Have people got snapped?
There's not a lot of people
running around New York City, for example.
Does that mean that all those characters
like Punisher, Daredevil,
Hawkeye Ronin
also ran into each other at that same time?
Like, did they become brothers during that period?
my assumption right now,
without more details from Marvel,
is that they did run into each other,
but they're not like super close brothers.
Like they're not super best friends
just because what they were doing was so hardcore.
And it doesn't sound like Hawkeye
Ronin spent a lot of time making friends,
quote unquote, during the five year
time up like he was busy.
don't have time to hang out
and have drinks with people.
Got to go kill some other people
on the other side of the planet.
it sounds like, though.
Daredevil Punisher
stayed pretty local to New York City, though, end,
while they were doing all that,
Kingpin was busy rebuilding his power base.
Like during the Echo series
they show him during the five year time jump.
The cops are already super afraid of him
and basically let him do whatever he wants to do.
Like he walks right through, then grabs Echo,
then pulls out like, No, no, there's no way
you're arresting her. I'm going to take her.
means that when this is taking place,
he'd already been in prison after the end of Daredevil
season three in been out of prison
and seems like he'd rebuilt a lot of his power base.
I just did a video about them bringing back Foggy
Nelson and Karen Page
in a much bigger way in this newer version of Daredevil
Born Again that they're redoing.
even in the old version when they were going
to have killed them off before the events of episode
one or at some point during the events of episode one,
everybody was really pissed off about that.
Punisher was still meant to come back
and be a big character during season one.
They just weren't doing a lot of Foggy
Nelson and Karen Page.
it was actually their storyline that probably changed
the most in this new version of the show.
like even the old showrunners
that were originally working on
the series were going to bring Punisher back
for a big storyline.
it's not just meant to be a simple cameo
or anything like that.
Like, Hey, I'm The Punisher,
Remember me from the Netflix series?
it's actually meant to be a substantial storyline.
I don't know if it's just going to be
for the first half of the season like those first nine
episodes or will be all 18 episodes
because there are a bunch of other characters
that they're bringing onto the series.
even though Kingpin is always going to be the main
antagonist in a bigger sense,
the actual main villain when the show picks up
is supposed to be the news character
from the more recent Daredevil comics.
He's a relatively new villain.
They just introduced
and because of the events of the Marvel Netflix
series Daredevil is not Fighting Punisher
or anything like that.
Like they're not each other's antagonists.
White, Tiger is also supposed to show up at some point
during season one.
Not exactly sure when that's going to happen
and the only other Marvel Netflix defender
character that I know was supposed to show up
during season one was supposed to be Jessica Jones.
I don't know exactly when that's going to be.
There were some scheduling issues
they had, but that was last year
when they were filming the original version of the show
before they rebooted everything.
Jessica Jones
was meant to have a much bigger storyline.
They were supposed to tease her during the Echo series,
so there was obviously a lot of stuff that changed.
for the actors.
Krysten Ritter was teasing.
Coming back in the new Marvel MCU stuff.
the only things we know right now about Punisher
storyline during season one
is that when episode one picks
up, he's supposed to be taking down corrupt cops.
And I think there was an aspect where they were
borrowing some details from real life in the corrupt
cops were using his Punisher symbol, doing
all kinds of shady stuff, killing innocent people.
the way that this crosses over with.
The bigger storyline in Daredevil Born Again
is the whole major kingpin of it all.
So during the Echo Post-Credits scene
they tease that kingpin gets the idea
to run for mayor of New York City, but they make
all these boxing references like hardcore brawling.
References.
Just teasing the upcoming conflict
he's going to have with Daredevil.
But also Kingpin is a prized fighter in the comics
too, supposedly
when episode one picks
up, Kingpin will have already become mayor.
Like there'll be a small time jump
like we're talking about 2026 inside the MCU.
and part of what he does
is running for mayor on an anti vigilante campaign,
secretly using that to get rid of characters
like Punisher, Daredevil, Spider-Man, for instance.
We've been talking about Kingpin going up against
Spider-Man and Spider-Man for pretty much
all of the actors, like Tom Holland, Charlie Cox
have been teasing Daredevil Spider-Man team up.
but you can kind of see the direction this is headed.
So Punisher trying to take out corrupt cops
typical kingpin trying to spin things,
but secretly trying to get rid of them, making it seem
like Punisher is just trying to kill regular cops.
Like, this is really bad.
We need to stop him from doing this.
if you haven't watched those original Daredevil Netflix
episodes like Kingpin actually did stuff like this
all the time on that show,
like even back as early as season one,
he was trying to discredit Daredevil, for instance,
and then eventually Punisher buy.
Basically lying in the press
and just making it seem like spinning things.
Vought style.
Like we're making more boys
references, basically just telling the public
whatever it took to get them to believe
the Daredevil Punisher, these other characters
were actually the real villains and he was the hero
it's meant to usher in this sort of Marvel Phase
five Dark Reign era inside the MCU.
It's also happening on a national scale
because Thunderbolt Ross
is supposed to become president of the United States.
So what's happening in New York City with Kingpin
becoming mayor is just like a smaller version of that.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
We're supposed to get a Deadpool
three trailer at the Super Bowl pretty soon.
So of course they'll do videos for everything
as quickly as possible.
We also just found out about a Star Wars
what if series
So try to do a video for that at some point this week
to be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss anything.
click
Here for that brand new Deadpool 3 teaser trailer
and click here for that Daredevil Born again teaser.
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!